MARINE CORPS JET CRASHED ON
TAKEOFF BY THE PILOT EJECTED AND
IS CURRENTLY LISTED IN STABLE
CONDITION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOT A
CRIMINAL TARGET IN THE
INVESTIGATION BUT THAT COULD
CHANGE AND THE PRESIDENT IS NOT
OUT OF THE LEGAL WOODS YET.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE HAS OUR
UPDATE TONIGHT.
>> IN EARLY MARCH, SPECIAL
COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER MET WITH
THE PRESIDENT'S LEGAL TEAM AND
CONFIRMED HE IS NOT A CRIMINAL
TARGET ACCORDING TO A SOURCE OF
KNOWLEDGE OF THE MEETING.
THE PRESS SECRETARY WOULD NOT
TALK SPECIFICS BUT ADDED...
>> NOTHING HAS CHANGED.
DO.
NONE OF THIS COMES AS MUCH OF A
SURPRISE.
>> FOX NEWS HAS LAUNCHED A MARCH
CONVERSATION WITH MOTHER WAS
OVER A POSSIBLE IN-PERSON
INTERVIEW.
A LEADING DEFENSE ATTORNEY SAYS
IT WAS A WITNESS OF THE LOWEST
LEVEL, THEN BECOME A SUBJECT,
AND THAT ULTIMATELY BECOME A
CRIMINAL TARGET.
FOR NOW, THE PRESIDENT IS
CONSIDERED A SUBJECT OR WITNESS
IN THE RUSH APPROPRIATE >> AND A
PROSECUTOR TELLS YOU THAT YOUR
CLIENT IS A WITNESS, A
SUBJECT, OR A TARGET, THAT COULD
CHANGE IF THE PROSECUTOR LEARNS
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
>> JOHN DOWD, TRUMP'S LEAD
ATTORNEY, WAS OPPOSED TO TRUMP
APPEARING IN FRONT OF THE
HE RESIGNED FROM THE CASE
AFTERWARDS THE PRESIDENT WAS
PRESSED ON HIS POSITION.
>> WOULD YOU STILL LIKE TO
TESTIFY TO THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
ROBERT MUELLER, SIR?
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU WOULD LIKE TO?
>> AFTER PROVIDING MORE THAN
THREE DOZEN WITNESSES AND OVER A
MILLION RECORDS ON A VOLUNTARY
BASIS, THE SOURCE EMPHASIZED
THERE IS STILL NO EVIDENCE THE
PRESIDENT COMMITTED A CRIME,
ADDING THE MEDIA LEAK, THE
COMPASS NOT A TARGET, IF YOU'RE
STRATEGIC.
HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR ALAN
DERSHOWITZ.
>> THEY ARE TELLING YOU HE'S NOT
A TARGET, MERELY A SUBJECT.
HE IS A WITNESS AND EVERYBODY
HAS TO TESTIFY AS A WITNESS.
PUBLIC PRESSURE.
>> THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE
OFFERED NO COMMENT ON WHETHER
MUELLER WILL PREPARE AN INTERIM
REPORT, ADDRESSING ALLEGATIONS
OF OBSTRUCTION AND POLLUTION.
A SOURCE TOLD FOX THE MATTER WAS
DISCUSSED BUT NOT FINALIZED.
WITH AN INTERVIEW STILL UNDER
CONSIDERATION, LEGAL EXPERTS
COUNSELED PRESIDENT TRUMP MUST
BE THOROUGHLY PREPARED.
>> HE HAS TO REMEMBER THAT THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE HAS
BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR A LONG
TIME, AND PROBABLY KNOWS A WHOLE
LOT ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED AND MORE
THAN THE PRESIDENT PROBABLY
REMEMBERS.
>> MULTIPLE SOURCES TELL
FOX NEWS THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
TEAM HAS BEEN FOLLOWING THIS
FINANCIAL TRAIL, INVESTIGATING
WHETHER MONEY WAS FUNNELED INTO
THE CAMPAIGN OR AFTER THE
ELECTION TO GAIN INFLUENCE OVER
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.